today we're checking out the google
pixel 4 xl
let's turn it on so here it is this is
the pixel 4xl and this is the
just black color it's running a
snapdragon 855 processor with six gigs
of ram you can get storage
configurations of 64 or 128 gigs
it has a 90 hertz display which looks
really beautiful it's got dual cameras
but
no ultra wide which is kind of
unfortunate it also has these new radar
sensors which is known as motion sense
so this allows for faster face unlock
and other sorts of fun hand gestures
that
may or may not work very well starts
shipping on october 24th and it starts
at 7.99 for the pixel 4 and for the xl
8.99
the thing that i'm most excited to try
out is their night sight obviously the
pixel has taken so many incredible low
light photos in the past
so now with some of their improved
hardware and algorithms they say that
you can take longer exposure photos for
astrophotography it'll then use ai to
clean up photos for a better image
it is all set up i still have to pop a
sim card in this thing before we head
outside
i'm so excited to test out the photos
i'm also very interested to see how the
video is because they made zero mention
of video in the press conference at all
so let's see how it does on a trip to
[Music]
[Applause]
catalina
we are in catalina i've got the new
pixel 4. i've got my sister jenna
and the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to go get some
breakfast
and coffee could you map the breakfast
and coffee place on my new
pixel 4. well the first thing we did was
get a golf cart we did and we're already
in it okay
oh god oh god it's not stopping it's not
stopping
okay first stop
[Music]
oh my goodness hello emma
jenna this one's mine
look at that bagel i'm gonna zoom into
it just really
get into the crevasse the pictures look
good
but like the composition like how do i
make this look good
i don't think i can maybe for the coffee
pop the top off and get some some of
that texture on the
on the top all right oh that's nice oh
that's a nice texture
maybe i'll take a selfie with it the
front facing is a little more wide angle
which is nice
but then as soon as you switch to video
it's not very wide at all
so let's switch to video so you guys can
see it zooms in so much
here's the video test
[Music]
oh my god holy this is so
good where are we
catalina coffee and cookie you gotta
come here for a ice vanilla latte
[Music]
so we've been driving around catalina
getting some photos and some videos and
so far one of my favorite features
is the dual exposure mode that they have
so you can adjust the highlights and the
shadows on the fly and what's cool with
the live hdr plus is when you're taking
a photo
what you see in the viewfinder is
actually the photo that you're taking so
before
it used to have to do a lot of
processing and computing to actually
make that photo be
what it is but now the viewfinder is
showing you the actual picture which is
great because sometimes you just kind of
have to guess
like is this photo going to look good
and obviously the new pixel 4
does not have the highest video specs so
comparing this to the iphone is almost
kind of unfair
but the fact that this phone is starting
at 800 and you're not even getting a 4k
front-facing camera that to me is a
little bit upsetting but honestly
for most people like it's not going to
make that huge of a difference but now i
feel like most new phones that are
coming out that are going to be rivaling
the iphone
you should definitely have 4k
front-facing video so i've taken a few
photos so far
and looking at some of these like the
portrait mode
this picture of jenna right here like
i'm looking around
like her hairline and around the
sunglasses and it
did a pretty great job here's a few
other pictures that i took these
are some little birds getting a little
birdie bath
the choice to not put an ultra wide
camera
on this phone is kind of shocking i
don't know i really like the look of
ultrawide photos
so i definitely have missed that the
front-facing camera is a little bit
wider review so let me take a selfie
here
now i want to take a picture using the
iphone just with the regular
front facing not with the wide angle
mode and you'll see that there's a huge
difference between
those photos did the did wait a minute
the pixel flipped the front facing so
it's
that's not what i actually look like
like with all this technology that's
built into this phone wouldn't you think
that they would automatically flip this
front-facing picture
to be the right way
obviously i haven't got a chance to
check out the night sight yet so that's
something that i cannot wait to try out
so as soon as the sun goes down
that's gonna be one of the first things
that i test the video shoots at 1080
30 60 or 120 and you can shoot 240 720
and 4k
30. so now this doesn't shoot 4k 60 and
the front-facing camera also only shoots
1080 30. all right
let's go take some more photos so now
we're gonna head up i think over here
somewhere wait a minute over there
that's where we're gonna go
this right now is the front-facing
camera we're gonna hop back into the
golf cart
and head up to the top of the mountain
jen you're having a fun time
it's a very lovely day today it is
actually very lovely
[Music]
this is 8x zoom
8x zoom hi what is he eating
[Music]
this is so exciting the sun is finally
setting which means we can test
out night mode it's not that dark yet
but the light is definitely lower
than it was when the sun is up that's
what happens at sunset
the sun goes down i'm so glad that i
could be here to teach you about these
very important life lessons we're going
to set up for a time lapse here
i think this will look nice
okay what do i want this shot
oh that looks cool i'm gonna hit record
[Music]
now
front facing camera here is a little bit
lower the light the sun
has kind of gone down we're hoping to
see the sunset and then we realize that
the sun sets
on the complete opposite side of the
island so we're not going to see it
but the view is so beautiful got some
food photos
and overall it's been a great day let's
flip to the back camera now
i was like well i didn't take it and
then he tried to get me to shoot his
daughter's wedding
oh some people just asked jenna
if she took a photo on her macbook like
the picture of catalina and then they
proceeded to ask her if they would shoot
the daughter's wedding back facing
camera
look what we have here see if you can
adjust
the exposure a little that's nice
is it dark enough for night sight yet
[Music]
let's take a regular picture then
i don't think it's dark enough the
nightside version kind of just looks
a little bit more yellow i think it
needs to be darker
[Music]
okay maybe take one with the iphone
let's just do a little comparison while
we're here because we're here
[Music]
we need dark dark dark but this is
pretty dark
there's lots of lights there is
what about over here look it's it's
telling you to try night sight
this is cool okay we're gonna try it
this is also difficult because it's
water
now we'll do regular without night sight
we
definitely need some darker conditions i
want to test this out
okay let's test it out on iphone oh
okay we're finally making progress here
look at this before and after
it's almost like it's freaking daytime
i'm definitely gonna have to look at
these some more on a computer so i put
them side by side because obviously
these are two different screens so it's
really hard to tell
but wow i'm pretty impressed so far with
both the iphone and the pixel
and now it's pretty dark so these photos
that we're taking now
this is legit
[Music]
so i feel like the iphone does such a
quicker job at getting basically the
same shot so let's time them
[Music]
iphone is done already we're still
holding still
like what the heck are you doing that
whole time
the iphone has already processed it and
this also took some time to process
so it's weird because the pixel takes
like three times as long to take
basically the same shot of the iphone
we have to head back to la now but this
is
pretty dark here oh my gosh oh my god
anyway this is pretty dark so i thought
i would get a shot
before we get on the boat you got it you
can't be doing that
all right night sight this is this is
what you're
this is what you were made for oh okay
all right this looks pretty good
okay let's do one more and then we'll
try it out on the iphone
hold still for how long
three minutes holy crap this looks
incredible
oh this looks so insane
no way this looks so great we have to go
so we don't actually get to
use the full potential of this but i do
want to know
[Music]
oh my god okay but this looks insane too
and that only was 10 seconds
i don't know i don't know let's do
one more like this see what we get this
is doing 24 seconds
oh my gosh the iphone
is doing basically the same thing in
less amount of time okay there you go
i will look at these later
hi so i'm back from catalina i'm gonna
take a look at some of the photos that i
shot
and honestly my first impressions of the
pixel 4 i like it it's a great phone
the fact that it is as expensive as it
is in comparison to the iphone when the
iphone has
way better camera specs and it has an
ultra wide camera that's one of the
things that i think is a little bit
crazy brandon if his phone was way less
i think that i probably would have a
much better impression of it with all
that being said i want to take a look at
some of the photos and the content that
we shot while we're in catalina and
starting here with the ones that we took
at night because obviously
one of the things that pixel is great at
doing is taking those night shots
now there was a lot of light pollution
here
but in this shot right here it was
completely pitch black so looking at
these two photos side by side it
definitely looks like the pixel
has a little bit darker of a sky
so i think that what the pixel is doing
is there is a lot more of that software
enhancement that is happening but if i
had to choose between these two
side by side i would honestly probably
go with the pixel
score point for you in the
astrophotography department so this is a
shot of the building
taken at the same exact time and in this
shot
i think i would choose the iphone mostly
because
of the realistic colors so looking at
the pixel it kind of just added like a
blue haze to everything
whereas the iphone definitely has way
more realistic colors
so that one goes to the iphone next up
we've got this little bridge
scene here it took so much longer for
the pixel to process basically the same
exact image
but again both of these photos on their
own and knowing how incredibly dark it
was when i took this picture
these are both very impressive here are
two
shots of my feet this is the iphone it
looks like it added a little more of
like a pinkish
type of hue although it was sunset so
that is probably a more realistic color
both of these photos look great let's
not forget what this actually would look
like
this is a photo that i took with the
pixel without night sight here's a shot
of these rocks
both photos look really great looks like
the iphone did pull out a little more
contrast in the rocks but honestly both
photos look really good
i'm i'm super impressed because it was
very dark the face unlock is incredibly
fast using that motion sense because the
phone automatically detects my hand
and then as soon as i pick it up it's
already ready to unlock my face like
that just happened
so quickly i'm going to test out one of
the live wallpapers
so there's a little pokemon one
oh there it is
waves back like it's following my hand
like that's so weird
completely unnecessary but if you're
gonna get a pixel 4 like this is why you
would buy it
for sure i also want to show you the
motion sense in spotify
so let's play a song
[Music]
turn it down so tool doesn't copyright
my video
and then you just wipe your hand like
it's actually working really fast i
don't know if there was an update or
something because when i tried this
before
it was not working this seamless so you
can tell when the motion sense is
activated so right here there's like a
little
white light can you see that look at
that this is my favorite song off of
this new album
invincible so good
this is really cool they did this demo
in the press conference too so you can
basically translate live
as you're talking so right now i'm
talking and i'm gonna click on
transcript so as i'm talking it is
automatically
changing what i'm saying to text but the
best part about it is i'm gonna say
tyler's name
tyler tyler tyler tyler tyler i'm just
gonna keep saying his name and then
when i hit stop and i go back to this
i can go through i'm going to search for
tyler
it gives me every instance that i said
his name and i can click it tyler's name
and play it tyler tyler tyler tyler you
can click to the next one
tyler's name tyler tyler tyler tyler
i'm just gonna keep saying his name and
then when i hit
are you impressed he's shaking his head
yes i love this for like
meetings or even if we're doing like
notes or something or like script taking
which i guess i don't really write
scripts very often but i feel like this
actually would be pretty helpful
the 90 hertz screen is beautiful
well thank you guys so much for watching
this was just a first look at the pixel
and i'm looking forward to trying this
out i also really love the live
wallpaper
ah pikachu let me know if there's
anything else that you'd like me to test
out with the pixel 4 or any other
gadgets that i have and i will see you
in my next video
bye